As we have discussed,
iOS requires military code signing.
This means that, apps that come
with the device, such as MAL or
Safari, are signed by Apple.
And the third party apps
must be verified and
signed, using
an Apple-issued certificate.
Now let's take a look at the process
by which a third party app developer
can obtain the Apple issued certificate.
In order to develop apps on iOS devices,
developers must register with Apple and
join the iOS Developer Program.
The real world identity of each
developer, whether an individual or
a business, is verified by Apple
before their certificate is issued.
This certificate enables
developers to sign apps and
submit them to the app store for
distribution.
As a result,
all apps in the app store have been
submitted by an identifiable person or
organization, serving as a deterrent
to the creation of malicious apps.
Furthermore, all apps in the app
store have been reviewed by Apple,
to ensure that they
operate as described, and
don't obtain obvious bugs or
other programs.
IOS devices are only allowed to download
apps from the official Apple app store.
And because of this restricted app
distribution model, plus co-signing,
it is very difficult to upload
malware to the app store and
have devices download such malware.